all right we have both a new trailer and
a big game TV spot from the Super Bowl
for the flash now I'm super excited for
this movie I know there's a lot of
controversy surrounding it right now but
I am really really excited so let's go
ahead and just watch him no
no tell me something
Another Universe
keep talking right so why do you want to
stay and fight to save this one
this is the world where my mom lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other with
[Music]
my face
so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea that's how much this
can be Bruce I could fix things Bruce
you could also destroy Ben afflecked
okay yeah he's odd
completely broke the universe
inside we've been waiting for you
I created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help Keegan
ah
[Music]
you are yeah
I'm Batman yo
what
and then there's if I'm Supergirl
there might not be a future
yo
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
oh there he is
it's not Clark
my name is Cara I'm more Barry
oh look at that
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this wow
okay
um
that looked absolutely
amazing it actually does look amazing
wow got a little teary eyed there
because it's so dang good all right big
game TV spot
foreign
[Music]
I just can't get over it
hahaha
[Music]
watch the full trailer online now
the flash only beaters June 16th oh man
that's just so good oh it's so good I
love it it honestly looks like it's just
going to be an amazing movie again I
know there's a lot kind of you know
surrounding it but
it has the potential to be one of the
best superhero movies ever with
everything they're trying to do and then
apparently you know the universe is
supposed to reset at the end
um we'll have to wait and see what the
plan is for that of course we know
they've done they've done some reshoots
but
that looked amazing it really did from
all the characters they had in it I mean
everything looks just just fantastic I'm
liking the story you know change the
future you've changed the past you you
know things are like messed up and then
are gonna have to reset at the end I'm
sure which is when we get the new DCU so
I'm looking forward to this but hey let
me know your thoughts about it in the
comments down below of course don't
forget to subscribe to stay up to date
on the flash and other DC news you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter of course as well and as always
I will see you all in the next video
thank you so much for watching wolf